Speaker 1: Let's go to Timothy from Miami.
Now, Timothy, are you in Miami or Miami Beach?
Speaker 3: I am just in Miami.
Speaker 1: Okay,
that's fine. That's okay. That's allowed.
Speaker 3: Oh, sorry, I. I'm sorry. Let me.
And my microphone here. Is there a way for you
to turn me down or do I have to do it myself?
Speaker 1: No, you're. Everything's
fine. What was on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Oh, well, I just want to stay. I
wanted to bring up a good point that hopefully
you could tell to other people. Sure.
But the thing is. So I've noticed that
the Republicans and the whole idea of the Trump
of Trump winning the 2020 election and writing the
lie that he did, the big lie is kind of like our
modern day version of the lost cause myth from the
Civil War. Do you understand what I mean? No, not
at all. Well, it's the sense that conservatives
are once again lying about something. You know
what the lost cause narrative is? The idea that
the Civil War was not about slavery, it was
about states rights. You know what I mean? It
all revolves around a lie. Word today it's Donald
Trump didn't lose the 2020 election. Joe Biden
stole it. You understand? I mean, in that sense.
Speaker 1: You know, I kind of do. Yeah. The lost
cause of the Confederacy is the general
narrative that really the motivation for
the Confederacy was to preserve states rights
in principle. And it just so happened that that
would also allow slavery to remain legal. But that
really wasn't what they wanted. It wasn't about
slavery. I just don't know that I'm understanding
how that is equivalent to the big lie.
You're just saying it was a lie, that
that's what the Confederacy was about
and it's a lie that Trump won. Both are just lies.
Speaker 3: I mean, I guess it's also that and that
and also in the fact that it's also being peddled
by, once again, these extremist conservatives
that, you know, have not really gone away. And,
you know, it's it it just seems there's just
something about both situations that seem because,
you know, a lot of time in American politics,
a lot of the situations that we're suffering from
today are often the same issues, often rehashed
issues from generations ago, you know. Oh, well.
Speaker 1: So I don't know if this is exactly what
you mean, and I apologize if we're having
trouble understanding each other. But one
of the things that that you're saying
that is actually resonating a lot is
we're talking now so long after the Civil War,
and yet you still hear certain political partizans
repeat this thing. It wasn't about slavery for
us. It wasn't about slavery for the Confederacy.
Could the big lie become that we're even a
hundred years from now, you still continue
to have people saying, you know, Trump really did
win in 2020, that, you know, that's impossible.
Speaker 3: I was going to say that, you know,
Southern you know, Southern people have,
you know, engraved this into the minds of their
children and to their grandchildren. And I believe
it's very possible they also could have tried
to change Southern history, you know, propaganda
films, stuff like that, to Death of a Nation.
Yeah, it's very possible these extreme Trumpist
conservatives that are somehow even more extreme
will try to do something to put into people's
minds that Trump really did not lose. And if 2024
does not go for Trump, we could be seeing some
catastrophic violations of history, freedom of
speech, you know. Do you understand? I mean.
Speaker 1: I do very much so. I do very much so.
Speaker 3: It's called I just same effect. And I
it's just something about it. I
just can't get out of my head.
Speaker 1: And well, you've said it
beautifully and I share your concern and
let's monitor and see what happens.
Speaker 3: Thank you so much, David. I'm
a huge fan of the show. Last time I was on your
call, it didn't really go well. It was during
by in State of the Union address. Okay.
Speaker 1: Well, I'm glad we were able
to communicate today. There's Timothy from
Miami. And on that note, we're going to go
to a break. We will take calls again soon. And
when we do, I hope to be able to speak to you.